good afternoon everyone welcome to this
meeting of cabinets do have any
apologies for absence yes chairman
apologize from councillor Wally Hawkins
right and I believe councillor Pemberton
he's currently stuck in traffic on the
m-40 so he may may Akito he may not make
it we shall see any disclosures of
interest take that as a resounding no
minutes confirm and sign the minutes of
the meeting held on 3rd of June is
everyone happy with the minutes a great
good matters to be referred to
councilman on matters for decision by
cabinet deputy leader place who of
course isn't here so as he's not here at
very short notice I'm going to ask mr.
careful to introduce each item so
without further ado John if you would
like to introduce item 4 Thank You
leader so members you've seen the
strategic housing land availability
session or schlau last time these are
some further amendments to that
technical work that went through cabinet
in June and the table of those changes
is set out in section 2 of the report is
further changes to just ensure the the
final shall are is that correct an
up-to-date version I just ought to draw
your attention to an addendum that was
unfelt you missed off the cabinet papers
they should have before you
beside the the basis of it is as went
last time it's these last changes that
I'm putting we missed off but I'm taking
any questions there's a cabinet any
questions any comments any debate will
do counselor kettle first then thank you
have you been through the papers about
the s election they are clearly we are
driven to a certain extent by
constraints well those constraints is
the County Council's unwillingness to
invest in further educational facilities
second school facilities in parts which
have quite a material effect on the
several business is that appropriate
that we should be cowering to the
county's expenditure plans in
determining our own housing allocation
and should we not be looking at how
where we should be and then pressing the
county to to reconsider their decisions
rather than take the solutions as read
Thank You councillor kate lot and i
think one of the things is coming out
more and more as we look at the housing
numbers and where development can be is
the constraints put on as my
infrastructure schools are a part of
that and i do know that there's one part
of the district where schooling is a
very very significant constraint and
money for school intends to be delivered
by housing numbers not just by the
county so i in all honesty in the short
term i do not think we get anywhere
trying to push county for money if we
were to look at a longer term view we
may well be able to do that but in the
short term
think so can't can I just make the
comment that from from that perspective
in terms of building schools even if
anyone was to agree today to build a
school the run into building a school is
unbelievably long time and sadly we
don't build things as fast as they do in
China councillor Barnes
I'm here basically about the
infrastructure found new parts of the
development have been put forward
particularly it on marcin army camp
where the me and Vale had the public
inquiry for recreation the four hundred
houses who now got the two thousand and
that public inquiry because the County
Council said the roads couldn't cope
with any more as you well know I asked
for a motion for a rail link to the
cotton city which I did expected me to
in there there's an economic two years
ago it was proposed by council Richard
and Morris have I think that we need to
have a study between Shepherd and non
Martin area rail and road link that
appears to be not going ahead situation
is at the moment is that the roads full
but I'm saying is you can't get you down
we've got a bypass at the moment for
roadworks and children at well for
school and everyone in half an hour late
because they've got to go down to town
situation is them it doesn't seem to be
looking to the coordination of the
problems that we've got with the
proposals which are only proposals and I
put forward and and I think they will
have a devastating effect in the
respective schools we've got a preschool
by 2 D Grange at me and Val supposed to
be completed in 2017 still not done
that's the new system where schools are
incorporated in the cata castle
yeah I'm Kazumi well we do but we've got
children pushing them everywhere now
it's on foreign places because there
isn't so all I'm saying is schools is
another matter but we do need to look at
the interest culture I wonder that I
father study he got that a year ago it
was sort of said well it might be too
expensive but there was my assumption
you know what I mean they snip and I
thought they're appropriate at the
moment that I speak you know Thank You
councillor Barnes schools have become so
largely a County Council issue but if a
pick up what I said earlier in response
to councilor kettle we are increasingly
aware of the constraints that
infrastructure places on us
and it's certainly going to be one thing
that else we review the core strategy we
will need to have a much more robust
dialogue with the County Council on
infrastructure I think the point you
make about the rail link to long Mastan
although heavy rail we knocked out at
the last cabinet meeting largely on
economic grounds we are going to look
further possible provision of light rail
because it may be more economic I think
it's also worth saying that if even if
we had thought heavy rail was worth it
it will be ten years at least before it
was actually delivered so we are very
well aware of the infrastructure issues
and it's something that we need to deal
with on a strategic basis
thank you video reply thank you what we
can do is fight on that's alone correct
councillor Richards Thank You chair you
actually you've mentioned something that
I was going to in mind which is that I
think we had the report of the last
cabinet about the heavy rail and so some
consideration has already been given I
think the plan to go forward with some
further work to give Caliban some
comfort as part of the Auvergne scrutiny
work program we have allocated time to
this the transport sort of thing so we
will be considering a number of issues
this is on the list and has been
requested to be on the list by some
members of that group but also from
outside parties as well so if it brings
comfort gives you some comfort that we
will we will be doing some work on it as
well to report back here thank you for
that councillor Richards and I think
that he's very welcome
because infrastructure really is a
critical issue at the moment with that
if there are no further comments the
recommendation on page 9 is that
acceptable to cabinet Thank You members
of cabinet so moving on again it's one
of councillor Pemberton's papers sorry
mr. weeks would you care to introduce
this far as please chairman certainly
thank you very much this paper proposes
the establishment of a housing
investment panel and in that respect I'd
like to just just make an alteration to
recommendation one in the report where
the recommendation refers to the
establishment of a working group the
paper proposes that this this new panel
has some decision-making powers and
therefore and it can't be a working
group it must be a Cabinet Committee so
there is an amendment in that regard to
to suggest that should cabinet support
it it will be a cabinet committee and
the function proposed in the paper
chairman for the new housing investment
panel
would be would be threefold firstly to
bolster the council's already active
role in abling program the counseling
ploys of rural enabler Sarah Brooke
Taylor will be no to many of you she ran
a training session here last Thursday
evening very successful well attended
session and she worked through John
carrots team in making sure or
encouraging rural communities to take
advantage of the the policy position
that the council has held for a while
particularly in CS 15 and as and
allowing local needs housing to come
forward almost pass ported if ever there
was such a thing through the planning
process but it certainly helped
significantly if there's if they're in
that position that there are regular
problems that are occurring that kind of
that that chain of events whether it be
access to land whether it be access to
funding where the some of our
communities are equipped with the
knowledge base to be able to weave all
of the strands together that's needed to
create additional new housing in the
district so the panel with Italy invite
bids from local communities for any
assistance that they might be able to
give in reaching that outcome and and
it's it's paragraphs one six one through
to 167 that explains that that part of
this proposal the second work stream of
the panel I can see as being where we
can perhaps shift the delivery of
housing that is that is already on an
already approved site away from perhaps
the more market-based product to a more
socially directed product now there are
there are challenges in that in that
clear viability arguments would have to
be tested but if it is that a developer
is coming forward wishing to deliver
more discounted market sale properties
than originally proposed then the panel
might consider a contribution that would
shift that balance back towards the
social market rather than the discounted
market sale
and the third stream that's specifically
what referred to in the paper although
lesser in volume but certainly equal in
significance is that of the temporary
accommodation program that the council
has expanded over the past 18 months two
years probably and we do have residual
of the 1.4 million funds available that
the cabinet allocated to that purpose
that could fall under this panel's
scrutiny going forwards and decision
making and then of course there is by
combining this panel with the existing
affordable housing delivery groups in
terms of reference cabinet could then
rely on this new panel to be its
think-tank its policy advisors for
housing related matters in the round not
treading on the toes of any other group
but certainly preventing the creation of
of to effectively subgroups of cabinet
rather than in this instance one
chairman if there's anything else can
help come up with I'll happily try to
append it to the report there's a draft
terms of reference which again is for
covenant to amend if they wish and to
help explain in fewer words perhaps a
bit more graphically a flowchart that
gives you some indication of what might
be deliverable with the panel thank you
Jim councillor cardille Thank You leader
I'm very supportive of this as you can
well imagine I've been pushing now for
an affordable housing organization for
some time unfortunately thanks to the
government's changes in legislation that
it didn't happen as we wanted or
expected this is I think an excellent
solution to that and my commitment to
the robert that helping bring this
forward brilliant however let's take it
a little bit further if we can I'll just
come from a meeting health and
well-being meeting and at that meeting
we were discussing things like fuel
poverty and then also
trained last Thursday we're talking
about the Passivhaus scheme in a certain
wouldn't work all these things can lead
to reducing fuel poverty but
unfortunately a lot of that is down to
government legislation on the building
regulations this may be an opportunity
for us to intervene in that part of the
market and improve enhance efficiency
the heat efficiency of houses and
therefore take people out of fuel
poverty it's something I think we would
we should consider as part and part of
the Rema to this is this group this
committee yeah so very supported Thank
You councillor Richards Thank You chair
you you I think that was involved in
some of the working groups in previous
years
so in principle I'm entirely supportive
and I'm looking at some an overview and
scrutiny perspective we obviously had
our first meeting last week and it was
described the papers were discussed the
only thing we had to raise was a
amendment to the draft terms if we may
this was unitedly agreed by the huge
scrutiny committee to formally request
that we tighten up the wording for three
status at the moment in particular the
sentence says that panel has the right
to report direct to the cabinet and
overview and scrutiny as it considers
appropriate we consider that to be quite
a loose and in the interests of
appropriate pre-decision scrutiny would
require formally request that the group
do put all its findings through the
commits or it through ose first so that
we can conduct that appropriate scrutiny
before passing it on all back to you I
think that is acceptable councillor
reduce councillor Junod
it was a specific reference to energy
efficiency insulation low-carbon housing
this made the obvious scrutiny committee
also agreed for a task and finish group
and to look at climate change and
subject obviously to day 15
decision but this would be an area very
much an area for that task and finish
group to undertake sorry counselor JUnit
can I just be clear that they Tuscan
finish group on over vim scrutiny would
actually look the climate change in
energy efficiency prospector then fading
to this group indeed the fact that the
government has not taken away the
targets on zero carbon housing we still
would need to be able to we could look
at what other things could be done to
make sure that in planning that high
standards of housing are dear to and
that we could push the boundaries as far
as possible I wouldn't disagree with
that counselor Junod I think we ought to
make sure that the standards of housing
in the district is as high as possible
okay councillor Harvey thank leader can
i refer to paragraph four to one bullet
point to the use of community led
housing scheme funding which is a
government grant secured by the council
could I be informed what the
implications of that are for the
council's finances mr. weeks I can
probably respond to it but John John may
wish to supplement what I say because
it's his money at the moment he controls
it with renautas help
there are no direct implications for the
council that is a government grant
that's been awarded for investment both
both on a rural and a capital basis for
affordable housing so it's not it's not
it's not capped with something cancels
it's not available to the council to
spend in any other way no my my my
thrust is as I understand it the council
secures this ground so does it is this
counted as a liability in the in the in
the council's of finances
even if I came on mr. pappan understand
is held in the holding account from the
balance sheet so we've received a
certain funding from central government
and then we can apply that to the
revenue account all the capital account
as and when that's needed so there
aren't any direct threaten your
implications from this comes me Richard
thanks yes so I'm gonna go I'm taking us
back to councillors units comments about
the tossin finished group we obviously
have set up tasks to finish but I'm very
pleased to say I see the council unit
will be chairing that with her wealth of
experience in that area I think the
important thing to note about that types
of finish group is that it is seeking to
bring forward potential policies that
this council will adopt once those
policies adopt they will automatically
perform part of the decision-making when
it comes to their so I don't think it's
right to include it within this terms of
reference but it will inevitably impact
the delivery as and when we get those
orders in place agreed and it will also
impact on the core strategy so looking
at looking at the recommendations on
page 13
I would also draw your particular
attention to recommendation 3 where it
does refer to the budget setting process
for 2021 sorry 20 20 and 21
so with that council okay housing
investment panel as a committee of the
cabinet so subject to that amendment so
the housing Investment panel will be a
committee of the cabinet so cabinet are
you in support of the recommendations
thank you now we move on to item 6 which
is a review of Stratford on Aven
district housing strategy 2015 to 2020
action plan as at the 3rd of June 2019
Commendation here is that the report be
noted revised milestones in the review
of Housing Strategy 2015 23rd of June
2019 be adopted any discussion or
comment members of cabinet in that case
members of cabinet are you in support of
the recommendations on page 21 thank you
cabinet item number seven use community
transport service review councillor
Barker Thank You leader this item starts
on page 41 with the three
recommendations the Yuba Service is used
by a wide variety of people of different
ages across the district and is vital in
terms of trying to address social and
rural isolation which is one of our
biggest challenges locally it's a dialer
ID system and the the contract is up so
we're asking I'm asking that the
proposal to extend and improve the you
bus service has described it agreed
fundings available through the budget
process and the exemption of Standing
Orders Panico determination of the
booking center contract be agreed as
well and the reasons behind this are if
you turn to page 44 and you look at the
contributions that we as SDC would be
making to various options with this
service the the one that looks the best
is where we actually get the most money
from the County Council which is three
hundred and fifty thousand pounds slung
into our pot purely on economic grounds
we've got that three hundred and fifty
grand to enhance the service and I think
we'd be mad not to as a result unless
anybody's got any further questions I
would ask you to endorse the
recommendations 1 2 & 3
Thank You counselor Peru Thank You
leader and thank you got Kelly Barca
particularly representing a very rural
aspect of the ward where I've got three
villages within three miles of Wales
born but no public transport whatsoever
to be able to go and see a doctor go to
the post office and go to you know
dentist as well so thank you for your
work on this I think it's absolutely
it's essential councilor jefferson
utterly essential I've got people that
would have to move out of the home that
they've been in for 50 60 years if there
wasn't this service thank you for your
comments councillor Perry they are well
made councillor Cargill Thank You
chairman again this has been discussed
at my previous meeting on health and
well-being and for obvious reasons again
we've mentioned about real realization
and the like
and also note today that stagecoach have
changed after more of their schedules as
well so they never tably means some cuts
although it's rebalancing or wherever
they didn't want to call it the only
caution I will bring to this leave it is
that this does cost a lot of money to
Authority and though I am fully
supportive of retaining one we must look
at the most cost effective way of doing
so
I appreciate council bog has gone
through this and has made a
recommendation on another pour and I
agree with that but perhaps is we ought
to think a little bit outside the box
and on Thursday evening there's a three
tier event hosted by the County Council
at the racecourse about this specific
issue and how we compact enhancer
service and reduced costs as well so
saying I think we really should be
looking at in a bit more detail
councillor Barker please rest assured
councillor Cargill oh this is just the
beginning and that I am hoping for made
major changes but big improvements where
we can stitch together all the voluntary
services that are about where we
use the app or the all the ideas that
are floating around at the moment
and once we've had the three-tier
meeting which I hope Rather's around
this table he'll be coming to which is
three-tier transport particularly
addressing the rural issues once we've
done that III think that there is real
scope for having a gathering of more of
us to talk about how we are going to do
this and I'm certainly up for that and
have it planned Thank You councillor
Barker councillor Shelton Thank You
leader and I obviously prefer being in
one of the villages that is really
benefits from this service as you can
imagine I would urge everyone to support
option 4 especially as in paragraph 7.3
that actually had talks about the
additional benefits that would accrue
and especially as I have I live in an
area where the average age is quite high
and they will take advantage of this and
also the neighboring village or town of
Henley and ardent so I've had me an
ardent wouldn't where impasse though
this would be a terrific benefit to them
especially in the light of one or two
developments recently so I would urge
members to support option 4 I mean
further the comments members of
cabinet's councillor kettle just looking
at the map which comes of Barker's paper
kindly provides it does indicate that
the significant number of the journeys
are actually quite central to Stratford
now clearly there are more people to
begin Stratford rather than the rural
areas but some of the more remote rural
areas are definitely usage is quite low
understood weather at the risk of the
budget but whether there should be some
more promotion in the very rural areas
to enable
those people who might as councillor
Perry has already indicated in in rural
areas might find transport difficult
this if we could perhaps get more or
shift to the rural areas rather than the
urban areas would be good yes you can
have a look at page 53 so you see where
the journeys are to and from so of
course people are coming in now to
Stratford rather Lots that's one of the
reasons that they use it and people have
pointed out that my own patch doesn't
use much in terms of hue but that's
because we've got the ships to link so
some of the some of this doesn't do what
it tells the truth as it sees it there
are other things going on and at the
edges we've got other voluntary
transport providers as well who come in
and out and dare to cross the border
into Stratford district I agree with you
that we need to expand it and extend it
and I'm really really grateful for the
support on this because extended
operating hours and things like that we
are going to have to find a way to fund
it and have some yeah come up with some
good idea so I'm looking at those of you
who are good at sums to help thank you
Thank You councillor Barker
whilst I'm not suggesting that these are
still interests I think possibly members
of the cabinet who were also members of
the County Council might wish to
actually record that fact under the site
and particularly in view of the proposal
that's being recommended I'm a member of
the County Council
I'm a member of the County Council I'm a
member of the County Council
so with that obviously a much valued
service which genuinely provides
something that's needed in rural areas
such as ours so turning to the
recommendations on page 41 cabinet are
you happy with recommendations one
through three thank you cabinet now we
move on to item 8 councillor Cargill
corporate strategy monitoring year-end
2018-19 thank you leader right and I
have mentioned previously that this
report I could say that one for a future
day right as I mentioned before this
report is work in progress I hope that
shortly we will have a review by the
headed Department on what they feel now
is relevant to be reported and I'm
hoping that we can take some of the old
metrics out and we can add new ones in
and working with mr. Platts we're
looking at alternate ways of actually
presenting this information or storing
it as well.they I hope also will bring a
few new goals to this organization I
hope they're challenging ones as well
because I feel perhaps some of these do
like a little bit of aspiration you'll
also note I hope that there's a new
graphical method reporting and this
trend will continue where appropriate
and I say where appropriate because some
will not necessarily be in a graphical
format and feedback is appreciated from
everybody on this one I would ask if
there are any questions on the specifics
of the report otherwise recommend it to
you to cabinet council junit i don't
know how best to approach this but i've
got a couple of points are different on
different parts of the corporate
strategies if I kind of refer to each of
them and
okay then on page 62
cs1
D about the rollout of the broadband
face to roll-out it's about six months
late could I have an update on phase
three if that's appropriate
you're absolutely you're absolutely
right phase two struggle to complete
during its normal period phase three is
just about to commence
it's slightly disconcerting that some of
the more difficult properties that were
identified in phase two have been
slipped into Phase three
however councilor Cargill and I have got
a meeting at County with both BD UK and
Council of core who has responsibilities
over at County for that next week in
fact so we're we're picking up those
points with her directly just to add to
that this is a rock and a hard place for
us we are gonna have to make a tough
decision one way or the other but we
must must get this rolled out as quickly
as possible the only thing I will say is
the two hopeful contenders for the
position of leader of the conservative
group both have said fiber to the
building so what is face counselor
kettle I've been here with BT UK before
and actually I'm still uncomfortable
with we are now as we've already heard
six months late for the completion of
phase two we have in the budget a
commitment of half a million plans
contribution towards Phase three
but as many of my colleagues will
obviously not the new ones of you have
the performance criteria necessary for
us to invest further money has been met
are we under a legal obligation to
contribute the extra half million pounds
and in the event that we are not might
it not be sensible for cabinet or
whichever appropriate party to consider
whether it's sensible to continue with
that commitment given the huge number of
subscribers to broadband in this
district who have services which are an
adequate at best and appalling at worst
and if mr. Platts has got other cards up
his sleeve which actually is identified
here about accessing rural broadband
funding through central government that
half a million pounds may go a very long
way to helping mr. platts deliver real
success as I'm sure he wants to do are
to those people who have seen nothing
but failure through BD UK resident
counselor kettle I would say that the
frustrations with broadband UK have been
evident for a long time I remember it is
going back several years when I remember
your contributions at overview and
scrutiny about being scathing about the
performance of BD UK we have been in
contact with DCMS over the possibility
of utilizing some of their funds to
actually provide rural broadband the
problem is you know soon to make one set
of contacts then they actually change
the part of the department that he's
dealing with it which is actually being
a bit of a setback we are still working
to see if we cannot come up with a
solution that we could actually drive
that would solve the problem I think
what is frustrating about this being
warm of our
targets our objectives it is that we
have very little control over what BDU
care does and it is a frustration I
saying shared by many rural districts is
the money do we have to send the money I
don't think today's the time to have
that debate about whether we're gonna
spend the money I know we are in
conversation with BD UK
the County Council about how we can
actually begin the best bang for our
buck and they'll come about with some
proposals about some of the money which
is going to come back from providers
like PTO can reach as they get certain
penetration within the ruler companies
which actually we could add some funding
to help even further councillor Richards
thank you taking some of the words out
my mouth today it's not the data about
how we can influence and as cancer the
catalano's part of our overview scrutiny
work for over time may stick consider
rural broadband I understand we're
receiving a report from mr. Platts
that's probably us at the end of a
meeting which is our next one and we can
consider then the best way to move
forward it may be interim measures to
ensure delivery of rural broadband it
may be a more long-term solution but we
certainly have that opportunity and
we'll be doing that and the last part
this year okay mr. Platts if I could
just add just one small point to that
instead recently as councillor Jefferson
says we were with DCMS down in London in
Westminster and it's interesting that
the government time frame has now moved
everybody back now from three years down
all the way back now for completion for
fiber to the premise all the way back to
2033
so in terms of rural connectivity those
government targets are moving backwards
as well as they attempt to
catch up with those properties that are
struggling so just to let you to that
okay so we leave broadband the counselor
Junod you had another point obviously a
monastic be kept updated on that one but
on page 63 there is mention of austere
leisure center facilities the Greg I am
being kept informed on that one so I
don't particularly want to have that
debated out but it just just don't need
to be kept very much up to date as
things move on that one and my next
question is on page 67 cs3 B which is
about the Gateway project is there
anything that we could be updated on on
this one because it does seem an awful
long time since the Windsor Street car
park has not been in very good condition
and any update on that one I would
appreciate Thank You councillor Junod I
think if we look at old strim the Greek
Center our frustrations are significant
mr. perks would you like to respond on
the Gateway please yeah we're in a
reasonably exciting phase in the Gateway
we've identified a potential purchaser
to the site who it's commercially
confidential at the moment we should be
able to release soon the current owner
of the site I was on the plaintiff
shortly before I came down here and the
agents are close to agreeing terms so we
have got some hope of getting that away
if we did that that would allow us to
sort of improve Windsor Street car park
and that keep access to the town so I am
cautiously optimistic that we should
have some good news in the next few
weeks on that one
go on councillor JUnit which is about on
page 69 lang charge searches we have a
major problem it seems here and I just
wondered whether again I understand
there what there has been changes in
systems is there any particular reason
why we've got such an issue there so
this has been debated a few times at
different committees over the last
couple of years just for the record in
1718 the council agreed a budget of
three hundred and fifteen thousand
pounds to invest in the modernization of
the service as the current systems and
records are not fit for purpose anymore
we have a hybrid system with a mixture
of different record systems and the idea
is that we purchase a new software
system and then integrate it with the
current systems and then the biggest
task which we are going through now is
to cleanse the data because some of the
data can be pulled through from existing
software systems but where you've got
information on card indexes microfiche
maps etc you can appreciate that that is
going to need an awful lot of resource
which is exactly what we're going
through right now if we'd have been
examining this question twelve months
ago
I would have been feeling quite
depressed because our turnaround times
were very unsatisfactory whilst we're
not meeting the government national
target at the moment I'm very pleased
with the progress that we've made in
turnaround times and remember that the
LAN charge team are having to do two
things there first of all having to deal
with the backlog and at the same time
they're having to help with the
integration at the system and the the
change in the system so I would like to
put in here a thank you to the team who
were working their socks off to make
this work
and we are we've got a dedicated team in
the camps or who are absolutely intent
on I know that everybody in this council
from the top down to the bottom are
intent on making it work so it's it's
work that's in progress we are making
progress and we have a plan and we're
reporting to the OSC every so often on
progress as well
councillor Richards once a quarter we
get an update on on the KPI team
performance so very clearly we'll be
scrutinizing this and that glaringly
needs footin e to me so when we get to
September when your next report comes to
us if you can give us a full detailed
report that will be really helpful and
then we can give it full scrutiny then
in in the right forum rather than here
come salute our deal
thank you I'd just like to clarify a
point though although we again are not
necessarily meeting all the targets here
correct me if I'm wrong but I my
understanding is that we are hitting all
the deadlines of new applications that
are critical before the turning it
around
that is correct is it not it's a good
point you make and thank you for
prompting me the April figures that have
come out are we we have a much leaner
turnaround time on all those that volume
of work came in in April so we're
catching up rapidly part of the reason I
think I didn't mention it was because I
don't want to be held hostage to fortune
on future figures because there is quite
a lot of work coming up with user
acceptance testing of the software
system which is going to divert the team
away from dealing with the usual
day-to-day requests councillor careful
changes topic mr. chairman page 61 CS 1b
Ethel councillor Perry did you want to
raise an issue on this particular point
I didn't raise an issue
I just wanted to reinforce I've actually
got some recent stats I'm keeping very
close to the land charges team and the
turnaround time is significantly
increased and for example in - in June
you know they received 126 requests a
hundred of those have already been done
so it's you know we're very early July
and they are performing terrific
turnaround times and particularly the
digitization of 12,000 different pieces
of information on card and through you
know so that puts it into perspective
how how much they've got to do in
addition to just servicing but they are
on top of it and doing some excellent
work thank you for that intervention
counselor Perry
I think you've clearly identified how
big a project this was and together with
mr. Grafton how complex it was and one
always tends to underestimate the amount
of work and effort that needs to go into
these things
pete'll I think you mr. chairman that we
now can move on to a new topic
yes Thank You mr. chairman cs1 be on
page 61 the very last sentence of the
end column expectation infrastructure
funding programs were introduced replace
SIL do we have any time scale or any
informations to the quantum or hammer
that might affect the sort of funds we
might receive from for infrastructure
projects
mr. kair furred Thank You leader not to
such the the replacement is to the
infrastructure delivery plan so it's
it's a process for spending SIL monies
as as opposed to SIL itself but the the
so that figures there we we have
released and received relatively small
numbers to date but we do reduce that
number increasing significantly that's
been move forwards thank you yes that's
quite clear for your very clear wording
in the thing it's just a very last
sentence that you say still is being
reviewed by government and that there is
effectively a new program being proposed
do yes sorry I'm so yes it's not sin
itself that's being replaced it's the
they're reviewing it and amending it so
it's trying to streamline how it works
how it operates and the infrastructure
delivery plans are being replaced with
infrastructure from these statements so
that's that's where the pauses are
slightly forwarding on that one
are you saying that count that
government are tinkering with things
again yes satisfied without mr. kettle
right having her there an exhaustive
discussion on this now we're now happy
to accept the recommendation on page 57
which says to note members of cabinet
thank you
so we move on now to item 9 annual
treasury management review councillor
Harvey Thank You leader this paper is
presented because it forms part of the
monitoring process for which members are
risk
it fulfills a requirement under the sip
record of practice on treasury
management the effect of paragraphs two
and three is to illustrate all the
council's capital expenditure last year
of 3.3 million pounds was financed
either by capital receipts or by capital
grants or by revenue contributions the
council did not borrow any funds last
year paragraph four shows that the
council has funds under management of 22
million pounds split between two many
pounds that's managed in-house and 20
million pounds that's managed by
Aberdeen Asset Management paragraph 5.1
states that it currently remains the
council's financial strategy that it
should not borrow to finance any element
of its capital expenditure the remainder
of sections five and six of the report
review the level of interest rates over
the review period and those forecast
over the next two years the broad
messages from from this information are
number one
interest rates have been and are likely
to remain at historically low rates for
the next couple of years
secondly financial markets are
influenced by amongst other factors
economic changes for example the effect
on world trade arising from the trade
conflicts initiated by the American
government and by political change for
example the potential change of
government in the UK with different
policies and priorities thirdly in the
context of financial markets where there
is significant uncertainty therefore the
council's cautious approach to where and
how its funds are held is merited
section 7 of the paper indicates that
Aberdeen Asset Management's performance
has been sufficient to meet the
benchmark that it was targeted to meet
and I ask therefore that this report
reviewing the treasury management of the
council's funds over the past year be
received
any questions any comments members of
cabinet I'll take that as a no in that
case of recommendation on page 77 that
the report we received is unacceptable
members of cabinet agreed Thank You
members of cabinet our capital budget
monitoring item 10
once again councillor Harvey went leader
oh this although this paper sets out an
extensive amount of detailed information
in its two appendices the purpose of
this paper is to keep members informed
of the progress made over the first
three months of the year in undertaking
the council's intended level of capital
expenditure table 1 on page 85
demonstrates the intention to undertake
expenditure of 6.6 billion pounds this
year excluding section 106 projects
which taking into account additional
funds of 3.4 million pounds we'll see
the balance of the council's accumulated
capital receipts and grants reduced from
5.5 million to 2.2 3 million pounds over
the year paragraph 1 point 5 indicates
that 283 thousand pounds of expenditure
has been undertaken or being committed
by the end of June and this represents
4.4 percent of the available budget
you'll notice that table 2 includes an
amount of 65,000 and 239 pounds in
relation to section 106 expenditure
which relates to the provision of
gardens and play equipment linked to the
development on Wellington drive-off
Banbury Road Appendix 2 sets out in
detail the various projects to be funded
through section 106 agreements which
totaled by the end of June 2019 3.1
million pounds as recorded on page 99
I asked therefore that members note the
current position and receive the report
are we sure that all section 106 monies
will be spent by the date committed
respond I can respond in general terms
and the answer to that I think is the
answer is no we can't because we are not
completely in the hands of just the
council
it depends upon other factors beyond our
control but I do know that there is a
tight regime on monitoring when money
should be spent by and there's every
intention to make sure that it is spent
as promised okay with that then members
of cabinet the recommendation on page 85
are members of cabinet happy with that
recommendation Thank You members of
cabinet so now we move on to revenue
budget monitoring item 11 and once again
it's councillor Harvey
Thank You cancer captain the purpose of
this report is to inform the cabinet of
the revenue picture of the council's
finances to the end of June 2019 I would
like to begin by asking members to turn
to appendix 3 on page 109 this shows the
net budget to be financed by the council
this year is eighteen point four million
I will talk in round numbers to one
decimal place if we now turn to appendix
2 on a page 107 we can see that the
budget for the whole year is for total
expenditure of 54 point eight million
pounds and total income from various
sources of thirty-six point four million
the difference between these two numbers
represents the total amount to be funded
from various sources set out at the foot
of the appendix turn in to the position
at the end of period 2 we can see that
in round terms the council's expenditure
of nine point nine million pounds was
1.3 million pounds less than budgeted
whilst its income of four point eight
million pounds was also less than that
budgeted of six point three million
pounds the combination of these results
is that the shortfall in income of one
point four million pounds exceeded the
shortfall of 1.3 million pounds by a
hundred thousand pounds or two percent
of the net cost of the council service
to the end of June these results are
very largely influenced by the
variations in the administration of
administration of housing benefits of
the order of one point six million
pounds in both directions the key point
in understanding the reasons for the
variations under there under the various
headings is the degree to which the
council and its officers are able to
control the level of income and
expenditure and the degree to which they
are dependent on for example market
conditions or other partner agencies as
paragraph 2.1 indicates it is currently
projected at the end of the year there
will be an unfavorable variance against
the net budget of 251 thousand pounds on
this basis it is currently projected
that the council's general reserve
account at the end of the year will
decline a set out in paragraph 6 on page
103 from 11.6 million to 9.3 million
pounds for the reasons set out in the
paper subject to any questions members
may have asked therefore that the report
is received councillor Junod I'm very
concerned on page 102 which is paragraph
3 point 1 point 4 about housing benefits
there's an unfavorable variance there of
nearly 110,000 as a result of an
unrecoverable payment adjustments as
people moving on to universal credit now
I think that's only for 2 months so 110
variants over I think just two months it
seems to be quite striking I wonder
whether you could comment on that can I
throw that one at mr. Buckland because
he understands the he knows who who
doesn't understand it better
mr. Platts the universe of credit
project has been going for a very long
time there has been a change of client
groups that have been taken on over the
past two months but it's it's over a
much longer extended period so that's
where the variance is accruing the way
that universal credit is being rolled
out is two very specific groups of
people and those client groups expend
expand all the while but we're still
dealing with the the earlier groups as
well if you like so basically the the
universal credit cohort is growing by
the month and it that the two month
period is actually the latest group
those come on board with it that's what
it is
so just I think if that is you know
given that has arisen there has been
that and I hope will be kept updated
because if as the universal credit is
rolled out that could become a more
difficult situation yeah absolutely
I'll do a little bit of advertising here
we're having a member training group on
August the first as part of the homeless
training as well where we'll be talking
about Universal Credit and the impact on
the welfare reform agenda in general so
if members would like to come along that
would be hopefully very helpful Thank
You mr. Platts I think councillor Junod
the point has been made on the universal
credit
reinforces what khemsa la Harvey said
that an awful lot of these big numbers
simply are not under our control
all we really do is administer it so
with that the recommendations on page
101 is that acceptable to cabinet Thank
You members of cabinet moving back to
the agenda issues arising from Obion
scrutiny committee non on bloc items and
on urgent business thank you
in that case cabinet meeting comes to a
close